hello readers i just got back from the
library with these books oh big surprise
you say i went to the library i found
two books no i get it but these books
will help us talk about the difference
between a first and second hand account
you see this is a travel diary written
by a young man on the oregon trail like
150 years ago whereas this is a book
about the oregon trail written last year
a first-hand account is created by the
person who experienced an event
first-hand accounts are also called
primary sources primary is another way
to say first or original it uses
pronouns like i or me it's told from one
person's perspective
a secondhand account is more distant
from the event like a book or a
newspaper article the author wasn't
there but they use first-hand accounts
like interviews diaries photos or video
recordings to stitch the story together
the story uses pronouns like they she or
he
not i or we let me show you more
specifically by comparing these two
passages
okay so this one our first hand account
comes from the diary of horus griggs our
young migrant on the oregon trail
july 18th 1871.
we're in the wyoming territory now and
it's been a few days since we had good
water
i'm starting to worry it's been at least
a week since any of us saw a tree
but the buffalo chips remain plentiful
at least the darn things burn hot
and here's an excerpt from a secondary
source our book about the oregon trail
that came out last year
the oregon trail didn't have many trees
the pioneers used buffalo chips dried
buffalo dung as fuel for their fires in
fact some children played games with
buffalo chips they tossed them around
like frisbees
so we've got here two passages both
about buffalo droppings good job me let
me be clear it's not gross they're
mostly made of dried grass honestly
what are the big differences between
these two passages
look at how horus uses first person
pronouns like i or we
or us he's telling the story from his
perspective and the perspective of other
people traveling with him it's like he's
telling us a story and it's his story to
tell he was right there starting fires
with buffalo chips
we can see how he felt about not having
access to water he was worried
first-hand accounts connect us more
closely with the emotions of the writer
and because he was there he can
accurately describe his experiences
however this guy can only describe his
own experience he doesn't know what it
was like in other wagon trains he
doesn't know what it was like to be a
native community encountering these
settlers he's writing from one
perspective and it's his perspective
now look at the second passage it uses
the pronouns there and they to refer to
the pioneers and their kids
what does that tell us the writer is not
part of the group wasn't there doesn't
consider themselves part of the us the
way that horus considers himself part of
an us
the author is more distant
it's not the author's individual story
instead they're trying to tell the
stories of other people through research
this is what makes it a secondary source
a secondhand account
because secondhand accounts are more
distant from the events they describe
they're usually less emotional
the author of this second passage for
example isn't worried about anything
that's happening to the pioneers they're
not even referring to a specific set of
pioneers they're talking about what
these migrants did in general they're
giving you background knowledge general
knowledge
that kind of distance lets the author of
a secondhand account cover more ground
they don't have to stick to the
narrative of one family or one person or
even one moment in time
first and second hand accounts are both
important
when i was a kid they used to advertise
sugary cereals as part of a balanced
breakfast little bowl of sugary cereal a
glass of milk a bowl the fruit maybe a
sausage some toast well think of primary
and secondary sources as part of a
balanced information diet
a little a column a a little column b
you just gotta take your knowledge spoon
and dig in deep into your perspectives
bowl
that's a thing that i made up just now
diversity of perspectives does a body
good
you can learn anything
david out